[Musique]
le toréador est devenu traître de jack
mais on reconnaît bien l'opéra carmen
l'oeuvre de bizet et revisité pour que
des chanteurs et comédiens vivant avec
une déficience intellectuelle ou de
l'autisme puissent découvrir l'opéra on
est en train de faire un pied-de-nez na
nana na na
mais pas n'importe quoi ma nana na na na
na na le spectacle a été rebaptisé
prends garde à toi
carmen et sa bande font la pluie et le
beau temps dans le métro et on peut dire
que notre clientèle est souvent victimes
d'intimidations de commentaires ça soit
dans le transport en autobus et le métro
[Musique]
tout le monde c'est un exemple d'un tout
petit bout en équipe efficace son nom le
bel assemblage des professionnels des
élèves des semi professionnels
c'est la première fois qu'on le fait
avec les déficiences intellectuelles et
l'autisme et donc ça pose des problèmes
particuliers et problème dure et
d'imprévisibilité aussi grâce à la
participation de l'opéra de montréal
cinq artistes de l'atelier lyrique ont
des rôles parce qu'une façon pour me le
dire il faut initier tous les groupes
quel qu'il soit tout le monde au goûter
l'opéra qu'elle avait 13 ans plonge
vraiment de la nouvelle déco mais j'ai
aidé que mes jeunes noté nous réplique
adaptation permet à tous de participer
et il y a du talent dans cette
distribution
[Musique]
oh
je me dis ce qui arrive pas chanter de
façon absolument juste où beaucoup de
paroles mais ils ont la chance de
participer de faire quelque chose qui
inquiète forme du coeur solide
j'aime ce ça m'apporte triton fille
aujourd'hui j'ai vécu quelque chose
d'absolument unique
je pense que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
j'ai été ému aux larmes à plusieurs
reprises des vraiment je me suis dit mon
dieu mais il faut que la terre entière
vois ça en 20 ans d'activités
artistiques en déficience intellectuelle
et en autisme
ce sera un peu l'apothéose pour la gagne
en rambo puisque vous avez pas vu c'est
l'équipe qui fait les costumes l'équipe
café les décors à maiden c'est quelque
chose cette année j'ai très hâte d'aider
à la pièce le 17 décembre
[Musique]
ici anne louise despatie radio-canada
mujer